vous vous êtes plus vous êtes paresseux
gr.i meeting rassure-toi roussette c'est
pas comme si on risque de faire exploser
la boutique iru black est ce qu'on va
devenir
on va se trouver un nouvel endroit mais
une fois mieux que l'aboutissement c'est
parce qu'à exactement tout c'est une
faute
ouais oui mais le maire de la ville de
le détruire
c'est plus chic mais ça ça fait quoi
je vais bien mais le prochain je vous
laisse vous long arrêt que ces gens on
aura besoin de tout le monde
tu me suis là trop mignon on ne traite
pas dominion non compris je m'appelle
monsieur feng la malédiction c'est
d'avoir de bons gros yeux adorable et un
petit corps beaucoup août tous je
t'engage je travaille en famille
et l'attaquant font souffler boucle au
traitement très nerveux
[Musique]
quand
c'est pas moi
[Musique]